ladies and gentlemen please welcome a
great actor mr. Al Pacino
[Music]
[Applause]
well we've come to the part of the show
now that you've all been waiting for
it's the halfway mark thought I'd try
anyway ah the nominees for Best Picture
are the English Patient Saul zanuck
producer Fargo Ethan Coen producer Jerry
Maguire James L Brooks Lawrence mark
Richard Sakai and Cameron Crowe
producers
[Music]
secrets and lies Simon Channing Williams
producer shine Jane Scott produce
and the Oscar goes to the English
Patient
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I said my cup was full before now it
runneth over
I'd like I'd like to thank actors
I love actors producers as opposed to
not be in love with him but I love him
and I love writers and directors too and
everyone who worked on the whole crew
everyone to work on the picture for what
they did in making the picture happen
when we were shut down ran out of money
everyone stayed there in Italy without
pay and we had no money they him and
then
Harvey and Bob Weinstein came through
and financed the picture and we had
final cut though and Oh everyone just
who was involved with all the people in
Miramax are wonderful and working on the
picture but before I want to tell one
Shakespeare story that I wish I could
remember the writer but I can
Shakespeare the definition Shakespeare
was defined as an early plagiarize er of
Freud okay I like it
yes I want to thank no two others not
the thing but say one of the best things
that's happened to Michael and dachi
Anthony and myself we each made two
friends and Michael's stunning novel
just inspired Anthony and then inspired
me and I can't say too much about
Michael and to a net thank you to the
boys on the corner
Myrtle Monroe and the gang up in
Berkeley thank you all
[Applause]
[Music]
you